laney this might shock you in January
it's the 20 year anniversary of she's
all that
I'm sure yep she's all that was a little
bit more like real high school for me
then real high school
so in that sense yeah that's a reunion I
would certainly attend
[Music]
she's all that turns 20 and only et is
with Rachael Leigh Cook Matthew Lillard
and yes Freddie Prinze jr. I thought it
was a really cool representation of
teenagers in a very sort of John Hughes
vibe where they were funny and it was an
extreme situation but they were still
honest about about who they were it's
just so crazy you never think you're
gonna spend you know five weeks or
whatever it was making a movie that
you're gonna be talking to people about
like 20 years later it's amazing right
I'm gonna do the dance tonight to
celebrate that moment how do we use
don't know the choreography what do you
remember most about that time I think
the dance I think being terrified of
dance I met my wife before while I was
making that movie not on the movie but I
met her around that time I remember I
was on a diet because I'd take my shirt
off for like the full scene and I was
like in great shape and I met my wife
and we're still married how do you feel
like that movie shaped you and and
shaped your career mostly just that I'm
so lucky enough to people go ladybugs
and I'm somehow remotely as you know I
can be identified as the same person I
was 20 years ago
Eleni you got a second your fondest
memory on that sense I mean that we've
never heard before
oh okay in that my event my freaking
that scene my bed my have bet and my a
bet Freddie Prinze jr. being a sensitive
soul that he is like really struggled to
get through that because he was like how
can a person in this world do something
so terrible
he's a softy so you guys still talk you
and Freddie not often but when we do
it's it's great and
his wife is a doll yeah rich I saw more
of them the movie also starred the late
Paul Walker I'll pick the girl then you
got six weeks to turn her into the prom
queen now in the age of reboots and
revivals the cast has mixed feelings
about anyone touching the modern classic
maybe seeing that comeback will be fun
to watch I wouldn't want to be in it but
it would be fun to kind of see what
other people stake with somebody told me
if they made she's all that today that
would happen in Reverse like she would
go get some glasses
and like I think I think that sounds
pretty accurate there is no rebooting
that story right now you don't think it
would ever get read I don't and I don't
I don't think it's a good idea at all
nobody should do that what you did this
week
[Music]